to some other news now with more
cyclists on the roads during the
pandemic police are stepping up
enforcement against drivers
who don't share the road last year alone
10 cyclists died in crashes statewide
hector mejia has more on this campaign
to prevent more deaths
police say they hear this all the time
when they pull drivers over the driver
usually tells police they simply did not
know about the traffic laws regarding
cyclists
so education is a huge component here
signs to share the road are posted along
fort apache in the southwest valley
but officers say many drivers still are
not sharing
breaking the law when they don't move
over safely
this is ccsd police sergeant michael
campbell dressed as a cyclist on
thursday morning
it's tough i mean when you get that
whoosh of a large vehicle
pushing the bike over and you almost hit
a curb a device on his bicycle tells him
when a vehicle passes within three feet
12 inches was closest that someone
passed me
and i have was also passed by three box
trucks including one that passed
within 26 inches officers from multiple
jurisdictions
watched and issued tickets between
charleston and desert inn
back in december tragedy rocked a
cycling community
jordan barson a suspected dui driver is
accused of killing
five cyclists on us-95 near searchlight
investigators say they found meth in his
system the southern nevada bicycle
coalition says it was preventable
that's why we're trying to get out there
and educate motorists about this law
to be aware we don't want anybody to
have to go through what those families
of the disease are going through right
now
in all there were 314 traffic related
fatalities statewide
in 2020. we do have several laws on our
books in the state that require
folks to move over a minimum of three
feet and then give the lane when they
can
there's an even bigger emphasis on
traffic safety with some
students returning back to campus at
ccsd on monday march 1st
reporting near sahara and fort apache
hector mejia 8 news now